bit of a late start here yeah new new
game blitz game playing again some
Norwegian at least the Norway flag
traditional master helps match never
play time I think the name in there for
the Walker doll okay so the night off
play at the Bishop b2 line I don't know
that this is a move and after that I
don't know anything
if okay sometimes prepares g4 I know
that much
I have to be sure b6 I think there's f4
I am
maybe maybe it's wait I just just
occurred to me
what about 94 is this a move in this
position 94 intending to take it okay
let's let's try it I mean cannot invest
minutes on it maybe this is an idea to
try to exploit this early Bishop move
I'm just inventing things yeah as I'm
going along I don't know at all what
what the theory says here grabbed it
well at least I got got the bishop there
I understand this is a good way to to
block it but I came talk to g3 but the
Queen may be mad allow roopd one
before him before it's an annoying move
probably I need to prevent it
I wonder about Queen G 3 2 H 3 something
like this attacking six pawn it is some
it is a weak pawn on e6 but it's not so
easy to get to it
hmm okay
what is this idea Bishop f6 and could be
you have 600 is a possibility on 95 yeah
well Queen on g3 looks looks decent
anyway
yeah this is maybe a maybe a valid idea
this regrouping it's got very nice
control of the dark squares Bishop g4
system Edison idea we should reform
it takes chief oh I can take this 6m
intermediate intermediate move
what I'd like to do is to play 92 to
define the knight on c3 is just a stupid
piece okay let's keep this Bishop here
attacking e6 and see how to continue yes
what about this 92 92 takes on C to 90
for analysis this is quite quite
something that I'm giving up is there
some way to play it more conservatively
without sacrificing all the pawns
not sure but it looks like he looks like
the way to go this CV night is really a
bad piece and need to activate is there
some other stuff going no no let's let's
do this you can take you form also but
this is what I didn't really appreciate
that it can just take it cover it I mean
not kid take it covered
so how to continue complicated bishop
official h6 may be threatening work f6
maybe rook is 7 he can I can play I can
take only six this is this is dangerous
I mean dangerous wrong word at the twins
okay so now I take on d6 maybe what a
position I only have one minute this is
this is bad this is hanging on undone on
b6 I mean
I don't know hey I have the suspicion
that there's something wrong with my
position but maybe I'm just good yet I
mean II six is hanging lots of times and
it takes on default Queen DeForest
wedding made on g7 and b6 is saying so
they are quite some things threatening
yeah I thought Queen e6 here or is this
is this bad yeah I don't have the time
to consider it deeply yeah
efore is hanging this is a bit of a
problem
that's still here keep it protected sir
maybe two we are protected
yeah it's a penny cannot take me to know
it's not open almost yeah
yeah it's at the time issue I must I
needed to play quickly time warning
yeah he's just winning on time the
position is nothing for him
probably it's got the better bishop but
yeah sir not very likely that it is
important
like for kids oh yeah I was sauce too
slow the game was really complicated
okay round here I'm I'm probably better
but okay Bishop e6 is just winning okay
yeah B should be six is winning me now
came I'm plus a bit to defeat too much
for for me it should be six check
cannot do this year a queen f8 huh yeah
of course I can take on a face
yeah then this is of course winning of
course just just winning material for
four-zip yeah probably I even would have
made this time wise it's not your
channel yeah I know Bishop takes d4 just
wins apiece yeah okay yeah around here
it's here I'm just a pawn up honey
before something but I was I was just
too slow
and here's probably a draw but it's
easier for him of course with a little
time can always harass me he won those
those pawns yeah okay it's time is a
factor it's not increment unfortunately
okay thanks for watching